citizens of the rack Nation it's me T
Eric along Aaron Alexander did I say it
well you did you said it so good I did
it so good watch saw five we're on five
of sa people up we're so ready also okay
don't forget you got to leave a like you
got to type in there leave a comment
tell us how cool we are also I forgot
that I've been wearing this t-shirt way
too much on here I do have other
Halloween t-shirts I olizee but you guys
are just going to have to deal with this
one again today okay next also ring the
bell ring the bell and also thanks to
prepper for helping us edit down these
videos we appreciate you and don't
forget that we call you super sexy when
you join patreon you got to get on
patreon cuz then we're like hey you are
super sexy yes and when you join patreon
you could like sync up with your own
copy with us and watch the whole ddy get
in cuz we' watched all of the saws not
all of them this is five we've watched
all all the ones before so if you were
like we want to watch the other ones go
back look at them and yeah send us love
we you know how it goes and also GRE and
John offer exclusive highlight videos
and watch alongs over there are you are
you ready you am I ready I never been
more for anything in my godd dang oh
he's ready and I'm unsure let's do it
saw
[Music]
five
always a lot of neck devices we've got a
new a new neck thing going hello Seth I
want to play a game this is the same
helplessness you bestowed onto others
now you served 5 years of what should
have been a life sentence wow I offer
you true freedom in 30 seconds the
pendulum will drop far enough to touch
your body within 60 seconds it will cut
you in a half okay uhoh all you have to
do is destroy things and push the
buttons to start the devices your bones
will be crushed to dust to dust
damn oh
[Music]
God wait why why did they do
that God oh okay that was an odd Choice
it was it was a decision yeah
yeah okay no thank you so you got to put
your hands in there yeah you have to put
your hands in the thing and he's going
to crush his bones if he does it and
then I guess you don't get s in half if
you do the hand thing oh God oh my
God no oh God he can't do it no don't do
it he can't do it he needs your hands
get s in half buddy just just just just
accept it just close your eyes and say
today is the day I die I don't want to
see him lose his hands I don't want to
see him lose his hands I don't know what
you did but I don't want to see
it oh my
God no no no I need my hands no oh I
don't like it I don't want it oh my God
this is hor finger squirt oh
I can't oh
God
did uh
what oh my God no
no why why is it not just one clean
swipe this is awful oh thank God yeah
just die just die die oh what someone
watching him
who
that oh God bless it
no oh my
goodness he's free yay he's he made it
he won he he did it oh he won death oh
wow that's how you play the game okay
all right oh flashbacks this is what we
where we were
yes let me see your hands we see your
hands is
death damn that's right that happened
yeah that's from three
yep oh that's right cuz the the cop was
actually he's actually bad he actually
working with them he I had already
forgotten
that that's Nicholas Cage cop
yeah it's yeah the cheap the cheap old
version he's not old but the cheap old
version of Nick
Cage Nicholas holding cell
yes that's
funny it's green and it's
glowing this where the daughter is Maybe
please save this little girl oh there's
the tape okay this little girl's been in
there for two movies can we save this
this kid please I know right is there a
way is she alive still come on I hope so
this two through five seemingly are
happening at the same time so I would
hope she's alive all the next game oh oh
whiz oh boy wow hello agent Dr finally
found what you've been looking for but
is the discovery of my body enough
there's no way to uncover the truth do
not proceed for this room can either be
your Sanctuary or it can be your grave
there's no way this man is this smart to
plan all of this in advance yeah I do
not believe it this cop didn't oh wait
is he who's the ex-wife oh no the
ex-wife with the keychain yall remember
from the last movie that's not his it's
the saw ex-wife but this detective
didn't have anything personal that
connected him to these cases so I feel
like there's no way he could have
assumed that he would have made it to
the last exactly cuz didn't he come from
like a different division or something
like that yeah yes how did he know you
couldn't have possibly planned this
maybe he's just so smart he's he's just
the smartest is so smart he's just has
so many smarticles inside of his his
little head inside of his
brain
okay did he just die right now no he
knocked him out he sedated him I was
like okay that made him a little
sleepy that's kind of cool looking just
his
head where's got oh
uh-oh oh my God it looks like his head's
not really there
right okay what's this game what are we
doing what are we doing movie is this
going to drop in like acid again there's
oh he'll just drown it'll fill up with
water and he'll drown hter okay he'll
suffocate via
water just his head though that's C
just drink it all drink it all time to
get thirsty that's two gallons easy
you've been asleep for a while you're
probably
dehydrated that's right buddy yeah okay
no that's not what you're supposed to
do you didn't feel that what is this for
you have a pen there's no way
oh my God he is intubating
himself
[Applause]
oh that's smart smart guy good job I
enjoy that move would you think to do
that no I would definitely not I
wouldn't even know where to I mean now I
would definitely make a mistake wouldd
well you stuck a a knife into your
throat I mean a p
the hell no what happened where's rig
tried to help he didn't make it you're a
fake we got a live one a swindler he
is oh but he didn't see him right
oh there she is I know she's going to
come back with that key on her chest
what's it for what's it for yep we I
need to know and if it's still doesn't
lead to anything I might be upset I
definitely be upset why am I here I
represent your ex-husband John you can
understand my surprise when I found out
who he really was John left something
for you is it a box for that key yeah
it's just a dumb bag with a tape in it
if you're watching this Jill I'm long
gone from this world you are my heart
you always have been I'm leaving you a
box today I deeply believe in you and I
believe that you will know what to do
with these
materials is it locked do you make a
little K where is it just like anyone
can open it
oh called it called it she did it she's
so smart she got smarticles look at her
wow wow foreshadowing let's
go hell no is it a head what is it girl
girl is it a head of a man that is dead
the jigsaw murders are
over why isn't this a joint press
conference with the FBI please not today
Miss Jenkins don't worry about it
officers who gave their lives are being
honored here today but today I'd like to
offer a special honor Danny Glover from
the first one yeah today we honor the
newly promoted detective Lieutenant
Markman life should be cherished Justice
is the backbone to every peaceful
Society and I believe the true justice
has been served jigsaws Justice I want
to talk to Jill tuck one last time
you're no longer handling the case Peter
I need to tuck in this case yeah jigsaw
is dead how many lives did I inevitably
save by endangering yourself and others
you're off the case on Whose orders mine
also cuz there's no way you can carry
through the rest of this movie having to
do that horse voice yeah I know D there
no way I can't like no that hurt me
listening to that really did I was like
no no why man or something come on now
let him drink some tea before he house
back
in wait who's that is that the hey girl
hey who is it who that
be JSA found
dead I know who you are that reporter
lady at the conference she knows the
truth oh I'm truly sorry about Agent
Perez
she said your name you know last thing
she said was detective
Hoffman how'd you walk out of that
building couple of scratches and a story
about how your arm straps broke jigsaw
doesn't make mistakes how is he doing
that been chasing jigsaw from the
beginning and I got him so unless you've
got something else to say back the off
and read the papers I saved that little
girl oh my God now I know where he's
from cheap Nick Cage was in Gilmore
Girls y remember I said in the last film
I was like he works a lot but I haven't
seen him in a minute I guarantee you
he's a Gilmore Girls guy he is okay I
had to get it out now y'all know I
haven't seen a single Gilmore girl it's
so good I believe you you should watch
[Music]
it
uhoh oh his little diaramas diaram
little trap
house there's more victims in there for
what what do these people
do
oh that's what we're looking at through
the camera is this
mhm
okay okay kind of hearkening back to
sawu a little bit with the group of
people people
yeah we're always gaming oh my God
that make him
good what is this we got make him good
the movie what the hell God it is wow
that's like the first big person we've
seen since the first one no it's not
jigsaw he's dead yeah well whoever it is
they're watching
us make sure we follow the rules which
your what I wouldn't do that if I were
you you do that it's it's Stanley 3G
yeah one pull pin starts the timer for
all of us like you would want to do that
unless you know how it works now would
you they're all actors I recognize
except the blonde from birth you've all
been given the advantages you've used
these advantages to selfishly further
only yourselves today five will become
one you are all connected a cable runs
through your collar devices it can be
pulled so tight that you will be
decapitated ooh the only way to remove
the collar is with the keys from the
glass boxes on the pedestal before you
one of you moves the 60-second Tim or
will begin your lifelong instincts will
tell you to do one thing but I implore
you to do the opposite listen to jigsaw
let the games
begin together as a team the brette
seems like she knows what's going on
we've got to move babe that time is
connected to those jars no it didn't say
anything about those jars they could be
nothing they're nail bombs how the do
you know that she's a fire inspector she
SE all kinds of DED [__] how do you know
me have you seen Man of Steel no okay I
was going to say he sounds specifically
like Jerell from that movie what are you
not telling us what do you know about
the rest of us would you talk to me
relax I am relax you don't sound like it
the less you know about me the better
the reason why you up your Charmed
existence is pretty obvious to everyone
isn't it that a rash what that what
playing with mates again have we I'll
you Dum ass God you're dumb that's why I
said you got to kill him bro yeah I mean
somebody's got to what do you do now how
do you even stop it I don't think you
can y'all are hardheaded damn dude can
you strangle him strangle him with your
own cord like what if you kill
him what is this guy
doing I guess he was like screw it since
the timer's already started
oh I guess if you save let him do it
then you get the rest of you guys can
go oh
God okay I think we're kind of working
together a little bit Yeah okay one go
we have three three of them got keys
already don't let that guy get a key
that guy sucks that guy sucks big time
not as much as the dude from number two
but like yeah not not as much as that
guy close
second let the girl get a key let the
girl get a key hey you're free you're
free so somebody go help the girl get
the key let her come on help my God yall
need to help that girl y suck
bro o o oh remember how I said I
recognize everyone except the blonde
girl and here we have it here we have
[Music]
it that was a cool decapitation though
that was a cool D
yeah all righty here we
go yet again another selfish complicated
white man just messing stuff
up good job
guy what you doing being smart job girl
being smart doing smart things she also
was the first one who was like so we
have to follow the rules so like I feel
she knows all about jigsaw nonsense it's
going to be Amanda part two Amanda all
over again you've reached the voicemail
box of Special Agent Ericson please
leave a message Erikson is my last name
except I'm not in this movie I needed to
discuss something
with track him down uh could you give me
a call it would be could have been aent
Ericson do they spell it the right way
they do hey that's your cousin hey hey
hey no criminal records found try
searching
again try a different
spelling there you
are oh good I think the horses is gone I
got you mother
motherucker ooh that's a deep
cut wait does that look like the girl
that was on his oh picture W that's
disturbing that looks real in the I
think so in the other detective's office
that's so
disturbing sister
slain that's his sister o yeah
okay boy detective sister sister
boyfriend who was
boyfriend killer strikes again how with
that guy just uh grabbing some stuff
from the office I'm I'm taking your
advice sounds a little better I'll see
you
around he's going
rogue going indep pendo oh maybe you're
right so see he got S I think it is him
I think you're right yeah and so dixa
took care of him because he killed his
girlf front or a new jigsaw yeah new
jigsaw you're right
yeah it's a little peeky hole what's it
for it looks like a finger go
through just a little finger
hole oh that's where he saw the eye yeah
okay I thought that was just like a oh
why did you not want him to see you if
you're going to K
anyway yeah it wouldn't have mattered
that's it's funny that he was like
shouldn't be seen his name is Seth
Baxter my sister's ex-boyfriend he was
sentence to 25 years got to reduced to
five on a
technicality technically got the perfect
Alibi cuz no one's looking for
jsaw I got you taking leaps here all
right dead woman worked for the fire
department not anymore she got canned a
month ago how the do you know that
you're responsible for this she had her
head cut off the Cs will drink your
radiation I'm going to close the
there was always some really annoying
guy just like yelling about stuff there
has to be there would be conflict
without this this muuk face what's your
story I work for the Department of City
Planning married kids no are you not
going to tell them about daddy daddy
yeah what about
daddy my dad is for trick he's been
trying to build a new stadium for years
a senior VP for Real Estate development
company so you're boring too
this guy is so rude the marsh group yeah
you can't get a permit in this town
without going to the Department of City
Planning o no
wife no kids that I know of no job I'm
an investigative journalist for the
herald you give journalist Vibes let's
do this thing before the BS go
on
[Music]
great yep these walls hold four
chambers oh is it sewage however to
access them a key is needed these keys
are in the glass jars hanging from the
ceilings when the clock ticks down
explosives in the corners of the room
will detonate with only three points of
safety which of you will be the odd man
out okay so why is the cop testing them
I yeah that's what I want to know where
you I'm wondering if it's a leftover
jigsaw game because we know he planned
ahead right planned ahead for the
detective so I assume maybe this was as
well this was planned in advance you
think this is simultaneously happening
happening as two and three are damn yeah
I don't
[Music]
know I got it
got do it do it do it no that's not the
right
one what the hell is on his arm what
happened I think he burned himself it
looks like a
burn better luck next time Rich
Boy
Hey You just kill that guy are they
really wow you murdered that guy he
would just blast
that's crazy I did not think that the
investigative journalist was going to be
killed off I was trying to link it to
where he would be like now you that
works for the h you know that her in
real estate is doing bad things and her
and permitting I thought it was like all
going to be I guess not he's going to
put stuff
together yeah that would have been
cool wait are they going to reveal that
they were like freaking
Neighbors
don't shoot the
doggy what are you doing PE come on it's
it's a dog it's a lady and a dog relax
yeah
bro do you
mind okay all right I would have been
like we need to do that again take a
beat recognize that there's someone
there he is okay that's I was like
that's how they met I was remember how I
said I but let me guess they're freaking
neighbors or
some what's WR you're going
to
O I think we're both going to the same
place okay you think he actually killed
his sister oh no maybe not cuz he killed
the guy oh but that guy went away for
prison he got out early on a
technicality what was the
technicality
o he makes everybody who joins his team
play the game yeah okay they say
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery but I find it somewhat
distasteful to be given credit for work
that's not
[Applause]
mine so this is in the past
oh we're still in this tiny wiy [__] huh
what do you
see huh Vengeance can change a person
make you into something you never
thought you were capable of being wait a
minute our game's just begun you don't
even know me I know all about you I know
you I know about your sister I know how
you cared for is it going to be a weird
relationship one of those weird brother
sister relationships oh they're going to
be those TV and sister brother and
sister aren't
they some uh some Life With Derek type
siblings uhhuh and I discovered what you
do for
recreation and by the way the blade on
your benum was
inferior oh boy oh boy again how does
this cop know how to do this trap device
engineering this doesn't I want to know
if you have what it takes to
survive it's your duty to bring me in so
this has to take place between one and
two this whole scene yes you could
explore a method of
Rehabilitation that'll permit you to
sleep at night we're not killing them
we're helping them yeah it's like
therapy man exactly we're just giving
them life shocking therapy jigsaw
therapy he's actually a hero if you
think about it yeah I mean for sure just
cares about their souls should really
get a Nobel Peace Prize for it let's
face it he's a true Saint in order to
protect a corrupt legal system that puts
murderers back on the streets make your
choice jigsaw get all of
them who's that one agent strong was
theorizing about the possibility of an
additional accompass to jigsaw he
suspected someone on the inside someone
with
access he's going to be like what all
the fires are gone what happened to the
fires I wonder who took them H it is a
mystery to me totally his accent we're
back we're
back you see this these movies give me
trust issues cuz I don't know when in
time this takes place I know right like
this is current right and but the I know
maybe yeah maybe this is the first game
who knows at this point God that guy was
an [__] but he was smart we could
have used him well someone had to die
would you rather have been you you
really saved the [__] over the
journey journalist that's
crazy Twisted pictures oh we already saw
that remember we had a a guy who was
like released and then he went through
the cage and was cut up
remember yeah see we've already seen
this how' they get you but wait is it
redone up now yeah I remember that guy
he's from like one or two yeah yeah
yeah oh are we just like revisiting the
okay the the earlier traps yeah
okay I like that shot with the mist and
the Darkness I think that looks actually
pretty
cool
okay the hairy Pig has
aun two and one has a cape one has a
sick hair like leaning in the front you
know wow uh pretty metal of that pig bro
yeah oh wow they needed
two for it it's okay Kate Pig's going to
come help you okay tag team pigsaw is
that cop
copper oh it's bald it's bald jsaw yeah
yeah oh freak when was he bald he was
bald in one of them cuz has the soul
patch again oh he was I don't know I
don't remember I think he was I think
that was um the second one between one
and two cuz he shaved his head at one
point we haven't seen a lot of him from
that time but I remember him being bald
with the soul patch I don't know how
yall waited a year to watch each of
these movies cuz remembering the any of
this stuff there's no way and I I
literally am like have forgot stuff and
we watched it like last week for like
did you cut yourself because you truly
wanted to die or did you just want some
attention you'll have to cut yourself
again how much blood will you shed to
stay alive yeah I remember this
[Music]
one yeah I remember terrible the heart
cannot be involved emotionally there can
be nothing there tonight tonight you
will see the difference between killing
and Rehabilitation so maybe he got him
involved before he got Amanda involved I
think that's what yeah he's the very
first one right and then Amanda that's
what I'm thinking his name's tap he's
smart he's getting closer I know who he
is tap yeah he he was the um is that
Danny Glover I need you to lead him to
someone for it was one of the a doctor a
Healer who needs some healing this is
yours
doctor uh this is before one this is
before
one you supplied these police files
didn't
you oh so he was the one that supplied
him with all of the bad people cuz he's
a detective right got it okay yeah he
needed somebody on the inside they kept
saying it but we assume they were killed
wow okay that's yeah
mhm oh wow I wonder if somebody's done
an edit of like this entire story but
linearly making yeah that'd be like a
major project to do why do you need a
Manda in the
game to ensure that the rules are
followed she won't make decisions for
anyone wow okay why do we need Amanda in
the game oh wow cuz she's just like
guiding them this is nutty this is wild
yeah if you're good at anticipating the
human
mind it leaves nothing to
chance clearly clearly that's your gift
that's your superpower anticipating the
human mind you just you're a little too
good at it my friends that's crazy we're
going back and and learning stuff about
two and in number
five what is linear time anyway oh God
that's who the hell is this guy oh
that's that's um yeah he's now yeah this
is yeah it's present day as far as we
know it's always a tub right always I
did something and a bunch of people were
killed what do they're still dead
they're still dead shouldn't you have
gone to jail for something like that
who's talking about Willis nobody else
knows what' you
do somebody does somebody does that's
why you're here buddy boy a grant
building permits and yes some people
might have been more deserving than
others but you know what that's the
business you take bribes you're Li you
cheat people if that's not nice says the
murderer the mass murderer in order to
open the five locks on the door to do
this is to find a way to connect all
five cords in 3 minutes an electrical
current will surge through this room
locking the door you think you could do
it I don't know I'm like you guys like
not going to reach how the we going to
do
this don't do it okay please
no
wait
oh yep I didn't trust you from the
beginning you working with the jigsaw
yeah she knew what was up from the
beginning oh right they have to hook her
up to it right
yeah shameful dang wait wa wait no don't
let your body touch
ours I feel the type of way about this I
don't like it this is like an like wake
me up okay
there's five of them so where are they
going to clip the fifth one around her
neck on her little nose oh
okay oh God it's to hook oh he has to
hook it into her throat oh damn this
girl is like she does not give a [__]
she really don't though all right hook
it in kiddo I mean plug it in plug it in
where'd you plug it in the back of the
neck all right run run Dam
bye-bye
now yikes that is wobble baby wobble oh
I think I'm being followed started when
John was first identified as a jigsaw
killer I think it's the agent who
interrogated
me another flashback or Y yes okay I
need you to set up a game it may not be
entirely clear but I assure you that the
people being tested part of something
much larger what's the end game here
amand will fail you we'll see is this is
one of those franchises you can just pop
in and watch any movie because you'd be
super confused yeah there's no way yeah
there a series you got to follow yeah
this isn't like the Marvel franchise you
can just watch any random one I mean
they get more specific no way that
anyone else called The key thing on her
neck right like there's no way if it's a
year apart people were probably like why
does she just randomly have a key that
works to that box that's that's probably
what I would have thought you're a
Pioneer I mean probably not there's
probably a lot of people who knew it but
oh oh this
just this just happened okay that's why
I was saying Amanda Amanda's gonna fail
we still have yet to see this cop and
Amanda interact and I want to see what
their Dynamic is like yeah we were all
supposed to
die oh
where's the B guy my where's
rig Peter where the hell are
you how did he get his phone I think it
was the two things he pulled out was
that clicker and then the phone from the
evidence okay okay
uhoh flash back again oh no it's present
day no this is okay as far as We Know no
I trust nothing no one me neither put
your hand in the
hole get your hand in the hole yeah when
the beaker fills up the door
opens fills with what blood
blood thinking arm is supposed to go in
there to fill the beaker this girl got a
lot of answers yeah this girl just be
knowing stuff I don't trust her I feel
like her hair's a wig too wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you still have
the KE from that first room
yeah it it's not even the same lock why
are there five slots in this
machine they would have worked hurry
before the bombs go up you need go get
her body she fried bro she fresh fried
the tub wasn't meant for one person we
we were supposed to hold one cable each
and suffer a small shock I told you we
only needed one key in the first room
the second room the three tubs are large
enough for more than one person from the
beginning we're supposed to work
together so we all survived that's the
game you're going to talk to the timer
runs out can they go back and get that
girl out of the tub and use her blood no
cuz that's what they're going to try to
do but the door exploded it locked
locked them inside yeah okay that's why
the bomb went
[Music]
off There's Something About This him
following him that isn't ex as exciting
as I think should be yeah right like it
for some reason it feels like it drags
and I'm not I'm not sure why maybe just
because the pieces aren't like yeah this
one's like very uh reveal and not
exhibition what's the when you reveal
information and just like our dialogue
what's the word uh Exposition Exposition
it's a very Exposition heavy and it
feels like the the game that's being
played is very like on the back burner
as opposed to the mystery in the game
was very much in the front
uh end of it a dealer gave me an ounce
of heroin to burn down an abandoned
building there was eight people in there
eight people died the feds got involved
and I got caught but I made a deal and
my dad got me off interesting the
journalist that buried the investigative
Story the rich kid junkie who was the py
we killed eight people and stole a
property and nobody cared wait so what's
her role in his his
[Music]
thing going three how is this connected
or related to anything that's been going
on you mean those two I mean she had a
connection to the building yeah I'm
saying like how is the them playing the
game connected to like this larger story
that we've been watching cuz this whole
thing's feels pretty disconnected but
I'm sure it's going to connect in some
way in the end cuz this movie likes to
do its finale
twist oh hey that hey
that God no I don't want it I'm good I'm
[Music]
good
no oh not the in
between not the webs not the finger
webs oh God oh my God oh my God no oh my
God no oh my God no no no no you're
losing so much blood oh man did they do
it did they do it they did get your hand
out of there get out of there
just oh my God what is it going to look
like I don't want it hello agent strong
and you have once again found what you
are looking for that's not Jake's voice
no it's the other guy the only way to
survive this room is by entering the
glass box before
you
[Music]
what
oh no oh did he win oh no if you want
anything it's a trip to the ER sew my
hand back together please I'd prefer it
in in one
piece I don't want to have three ends I
don't want
[Laughter]
it how did this guy know where they went
I don't know they didn't even oh was he
trying to track his phone but then they
couldn't track the no cuz he turned it
off so that's why I'm like how could you
Poss how did he know where to
go what's this what oh he's hiding in
the shadows
nice you're dumb you're dumb buddy
you're a dummy you're a dumb guy for
that yeah why didn't you just push him
into the box why were you standing close
enough for him to hit you that's my
question right right okay there you go
close the Box yeah close the Box close
the Box what's in the box JSA put him in
the
Box O he's going to be like this they're
going to set him up to go to jail my
plan you're setting him up to look like
jigsaw yeah cuz he's going to see him on
camera now right yep he's yeah cuz stro
was taking all the files out he's been
off work planting the seeds what who
that I said
it oh just turn where the guy he's in
the we just saw him on the
ground yeah you better dial that [__] in
I was like if he starts wandering around
without calling an ambulance I'm going
to be like you are not a real cop okay
not a real cop in your
[Music]
dummy planting them breadcrumbs so you
can frame the other
cop
did that guy implant oh so then that way
he was going to come after me
next this was all part of my
plan you can't
Mah however if you choose not to you
will never be heard from again your body
will never be found you will simply
vanish oh the box is going to the box is
going to keep him safe yeah exactly if
you're good at anticipating the human
line I think I'm being followed who
would be following you I'm supposed to
die you were supposed to be the
hero are going to leave us on the Cliff
Hanger oh my God are the walls closing
in
mhm all right how you going to get out
of this one guy I don't know if you
it's like a kitchen a for a human body
and we end up with oh wow we're going to
try oh that's going to work that's going
to work I think you're going to get
smushed either
way oh my God that's
horrible
oh no that's rough and that's how we
ended just out I did like that last shot
of that guy just blood falling all over
the case yeah that was cool cool
POV um yeah okay all right um that was a
movie uh that was a movie I'm not I
wasn't I'm not okay I'm not in love with
it give your give your thoughts you got
thoughts right away I got thoughts right
away I will say uh what's happening I'll
say that was the least satisfying it's
not playing the next one is it no it
just oh yeah let's pause it let's pause
that yeah yeah there we go
uh yeah I would say that's the least
satisfying of the experiences that we've
had with these Saw movies in my opinion
uh one I don't see any clear connection
between the players of this game and the
previous movies because normally the
movies are very good about connecting
these dots and weaving these uh bless
you uh weaving these things together
also I thought our lead wasn't very uh
enticing as a character personally I
don't think we really knew much about
him to really have us endear to him
there wasn't any moral plight he had to
really go through and just the cat and
mouse aspect of it wasn't exactly the
most thrilling and the game seemed like
it was obligatory and kind of on the
back burner to this back burner to this
story that they were trying to to tell
us which you know it's getting more kind
of convoluted as it goes along um yeah I
thought it was okay I didn't hate it I
didn't think it was like God awful but
it's definitely like even like the The
Twist at the end is not even as s
satisfying as it's been I was like okay
all right this is cuz not really cuz he
said the only way to survive this game
is get in the freaking case and we all
know you just follow you follow the
rules exactly you follow the rules and
the thing that that frustrates me about
at least this one and I think a little
bit about the last one is
that he tells you straight up what
you're supposed to do and nobody's like
smart enough to actually like I don't
know listen like he's he's giving you
all he's giving you the cookies like
here here's here's the plate of cookies
just sit here long enough to like not
eat the cookies and what do they do they
eat the goddamn cookies every time and
you know I wish it was just something
smarter about it
and yeah and also just the fact that
okay at least in the first two movies
right there were little seats here and
there to kind of if you were if you were
smart and really paying attention you
could put the ending twist together like
you know that music starts playing like
oh snap the twist is about to come in
but this one I think we kind of called
it even before it got to that point like
okay it seemed obvious that he was
setting him up from the beginning or at
least like halfway
through yeah um I I didn't hate it you
know I think that some of the the traps
were were still cool and inventive I
don't think they're as crazy as like
they were in the first three movies
they're just like I said they kind of
feel obligatory at least with the in
this specific film but yeah I thought it
was it was okay it's just like the
detective that we had it's like we
didn't even have a a real reasoning like
a personal connection I said this in the
beginning of watching it there's no real
personal connection with him to tyus
here NOP um except for like the the
other lead like I'm talking about cheap
Nick Cage was kind of like lead and then
the detective second jigsaw right second
jigsaw did because his sister and then
the guy right he had that tie-in that we
learned but then we learned like oh he's
just been working with him forever and
that's why he knew how to how to do all
the deuce I guess um anywh who with
cheap Nick Cage he didn't have a
personal connection which always makes
it 10 times better but also ski to into
right they're they're all dumb Dums and
they're not working together and that's
always like the lesson here except now
with brunette girl who survived from the
very beginning she says we have to
follow the rules there's enough
literature out there that talks about
jigsaw that everyone had to be like yeah
okay uh yeah probably follow the rules
like they have to be somewhat aware of
it they just do not all of them are dumb
Dums if she knew they have to have a
little bit of a recollection of it and
it didn't seem like anyone decided to go
like yeah let's maybe try to follow the
rules and which I think would have made
it a much smarter game to follow along
with but I think they had to cut out of
that game that they just placed there
that the two people maybe survived or
bled out I don't know because it they
still had to incorporate the two cop
story coming in and out and flashbacks
which I was like yeah okay we've seen
we've seen these and you're giving us a
flashback and you're giving us some
history but I didn't I didn't really
care and now I know obviously that box
has to come back right with the wife the
box has got to come back just like the
key came back this time she's just she's
living in all of them um but other than
that I I think that if the game had been
really good with the six with the five
people I I would have l to just watch
that game but there's a lot of like
weaving in and out that I was like I
don't know if we need it it happened in
kind of in the last one too um that we
were weaving a lot in and out between
plot lines and story lines yeah even
though this is obviously they don't
treat these movies as as movies anymore
they're they're chapters of this larger
story at this point yeah I would say
this is the closest thing I've seen to a
movie filling like film filler like
there was like stuff their Siege planted
for things to come in the future movies
but the detective wasn't really integral
until this whole larger plot because I
don't think jigsaw or original jigsaw
John had any personal connection to this
guy and the as of right now the two
players that were in this game there
there wasn't any like crazy connection
to this larger plan that jigsaw had I
think they were all they were all PLO to
to set up this cop who ended up killing
anyway it's just I don't it's not as
satisfying I think the further I hope
six can turn it around cuz I feel like
the further we get away from John's
direct involvement with these plots or
with these games the less interesting it
becomes because he just had this this
moral principle this moral code in which
he would test people and also he was
like five steps ahead of everybody else
and you saw that all throughout these
the movie you know and it just it's just
not as it's just not hitting the same
it's like it's like uh it's like Diet
saw at this point yeah it's like go back
to the originality that one obviously
really really held and two a little bit
too um those two um that I think getting
us closer back to jigsaw in direct
correlation with a game will make I
think saw audience is a little bit
happier if we just see a game there can
be a a bait and twist at the end yes
there's more people involved now I
understand that but we still I mean for
me we got away from the game and there
was I mean we had to follow I get it the
detectives and all that but it was just
I it didn't make it as fun for me yeah I
will say the movie wasn't as fun overall
but I will say if I just just like take
a pause from [__] on it for a second
I think that the stuff I did enjoy was
going back and seeing like the stuff
that was set up from the previous movies
to add to the lore of this whole thing
and me really made me want to see like a
super cut of the entire film franchise
we've seen so far like in linear order
to see like how this all played out from
just like from from beginning to end um
and yeah just like a a satisfying
faction like okay this was here I don't
know how they would do it but I would I
would watch it I'd be curious yeah cuz
I'm like when he when he pulls out the
brick and the brick is from like two
right when he sets it and we see the
flashback I feel like the little Easter
aays that they're putting in there if
this was set up well enough I feel like
I would have been like oh they knew it
all this time but like I didn't I didn't
really feel that way for maybe when he
was like I believe this is yours from
Danny Glover gave him like the
flashlight thing and then I was like oh
oh they like really play some stuff way
back when cool they did that a few more
times but it wasn't as like it wasn't as
like ah to me the same didn't hit the
same but but that's all right I still I
do agree with you I still think it was
it was um I do I did still like seeing
the games I mean it was still like fun
like cool uh kills I guess guess not
that they're like cool you guys get what
I mean like the Gory stuff the guy
getting s in
half Bonkers um and then what was the
other cool like who they had to like run
out oh the girl the decapitated girl
that was that was pretty cool um the
other ones I'm like yeah was stuff I
feel like we've A vibe of what we've
seen before but overall I mean it
satisfied that genre of it like when
people watch these movies to get that
part out of it of like oh it's a game
it's going to be bloody and gory uh yeah
it kind of delivered like I said I like
the the last shot of all the blood just
seeping down onto that pretty cool onto
that cof that was a cool shot um and
there were some shots of this that
looked more cinematic than the last one
the last one I think you we both made a
comment looked more like TV movie like
they still used a lot a lot of the some
of the same camera moves but I felt like
it Incorporated more um angles and
handheld shots that are like from behind
something that made it more interesting
uh which I enjoyed and yeah I think
that's it I'm just excited to see what
comes next to see how how can we use
this as like a a bounce board to be like
well that happened not in love with it
let's let's go forward yeah like a
little jumping off point little jumping
off point that's all we're doing here
yeah it's just a bump in the road yeah
just got like what like like five of
these five more or something yeah we'll
make it through we got this you got
words uh I thought it was okay I look
forward to the next one and I I would
say I'd give this movie like a 5.5 to
six yeah yeah I'm thinking I'm thinking
the same cuz I I don't think I would
want to watch it again I was not very
excited there are still some parts of
this that I do like but as a movie as a
whole like yeah like a like a five I
think yeah yeah um but that's where
we're at we're just being cool and
honest and we love you guys so leave a
like leave a comment tell us what you
thought we're going to be watching six
soon and um that's it we love you thanks
for joining us and we'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
bye